on this episode I talk about if I'm
happy ten year-old weaning and beer you
ask questions and I answer them
this is the askgaryvee show
every way
I'm just kind of indirect what's up
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
you're watching the askgaryvee show
episode number 65 you also may be
listening cuz we're gonna start focusing
a little more on the podcast that's
right
well we're in our office show AJ I don't
know if anybody's ever seen AJ I'm just
kidding AJ let's get into the show
Comstock brewing asks Gary if you were
gonna crush it by starting a brewery
what would you do
Comstock great question uh you know
obviously I've thought a lot about this
because I always do think about
producing products and selling them I
come from a retail background a lot of
our clients are cpgs consumer packaged
goods products that sell to consumers
and I always say what if I had one and
obviously beer coming from the world I
grew up in as in fact when I first got
into my dad's business that was the real
first boom of micro brews back in like
nineteen nineties five-six-seven-eight
it was a huge boom back then and I
thought a lot about that um look I mean
I think the thing that's going on is a
couple different things first of all I'd
win locally I think micro brews really
need to focus locally so I would
probably go to every local business
within a five-mile radius by hand and
shake hands and kiss babies to create
relationships so that they use you know
like there's a there's a insurance
company that's 147 employees down the
street in Cincinnati and you go there
and you become friends and they use your
beer for their events right so I think
localization really matters the next
thing I would really focus on would be
probably Instagram I would go all in on
creating a very serious profile on
Instagram and then using Facebook dark
posts ads to drive links from the
Facebook ad to your Instagram to get
people following there because I think
the 21 to 30 year old demo is living and
breathing in that platform and I think
it matters for you to win in that
platform number three I would really
focus on getting two to three states to
carry my beer and then build very strong
relationship with a sales team of that
small distributor because you're a small
micro brew you're probably gonna be with
a small distributor you don't get lost
in a big one what I mean by that is the
people that represent you know Budweiser
and Sam
and things that made sure you're a
little 500 cases a year gets lost
somewhere in the back of the warehouse
nobody cares so you want to go somewhere
small where you're you know a bigger
fish in that smaller pond I think you
pick two or three strategic markets and
then I would run Facebook dark posts ads
and Twitter local ads in that market to
build up some hype so now all of a
sudden I go your stuff sells so those
are some of the tactics I would do dawn
asks Gary I'm 10 years old which one of
your book should I read first and when
should I read it I can't decide Don
first of all big shout out to you
because at 10 years old I had read 0
books in my life
so I appreciate you debating the 3 books
you know actually for you you know I
probably just start with Jab Jab Jab
right hook I mean I think the Thank You
economy I think jab - jab right hook in
a lot of ways is a modern version of
crush it with less kind of boom fin like
rah rah and hype so if you want to get
pumped at your at your you know 120
months of existence then crush it is
interesting I think Thank You economy is
probably the one I want most in your
veins and your religion so that I might
even say for last but Jab Jab Jab right
hook has modern-day execution of what
crush it is you're gonna really
understand it better than a lot of
people in the vaynernation
because you're so much in a place where
you're growing up native to the digital
communication world so I'd go Jab Jab
right hook
crush it Thank You economy lean box
company asks Gary how long do you spend
creating a single piece of content do
you focus on video because it's more
natural for you lean this is a great
question and really ironic timing so
obviously you know for the from 2006 -
deep into 2014 every piece of content
that came out came out for me then we
started building this amazing team and
so I assume you're asking about my
content I don't think about it at all
meaning I have religion of thank you
economy crush it and Jab Jab right hook
and I'm execute off of that clearly
comes from me weirdly insanely that
we're doing this question today because
last night I started using Twitter's new
video product where I can reply with
in-app
and so I'm replying a lot more with
video and so when I was putting out
content to put out it was video first in
mine because I thought that was the best
way that I could communicate the reason
you're seeing so much more medium and
and garyvaynerchuk.com written articles
is Steve and India helping me transcribe
these things into written form so I
think that for me I did think video
first but it was hard to execute video
first for a while back in oh seven eight
nine I had a flip cam with me and I
would tape stuff for that whole process
now I can do it right from the Twitter
app they made it available for verified
users so if any of you are verified you
can go check it out and I just go roll
it out for everybody soon so I don't
overthink it I think way too many people
overthink it we're living in a culture
where kids are growing up overthinking
it every fourteen-year-old girl on the
planet is taking an Instagram photo
that's taking her 47 minutes because she
needs the lighting just right and then
if it doesn't get enough likes within
the first four minutes she's taking it
down I have the reverse of that rigger
the the you know Mike and I were working
out last night talking about like how
much I've leaned down and all these
things and then I we were talking about
people commenting and I was like yeah of
course because I would take literally
the most unflattering pictures of all
time I could care less about lighting I
don't even understand I'm I think only
this year I realized oh the Lighting's
got to come this way versus me being in
the light like right I mean like I
really really don't care about the
angles and things that make sure I care
about the substance I know I'm pretty
keep the lapse in I want everybody know
what the three of you thought about you
know keep the stop keep the scoffs
indie-rock
next question doc asks in episode 62 you
asked if we were going to submit a
question via Instagram I said no because
I don't have a smartphone so I can't get
an account so I borrowed my daughter's
phone to open an account and upload the
stupid question my question is are you
happy now Gary doc you and I have been
jamming and interacting on Twitter for a
very long time and the fact that you
care enough about me and this show to
jump into new waters is in essence the
entire thesis of what I do for a living
would just try to get people to stop
drawing lines in the sand and not be
religious and
and do new things and taste them and
then decide if they're stupid
I am happy but I'm gonna be a hell of a
lot happier in nine and a half months
when I go back to your account that you
just put up and see enormous ly
beautiful selfie shots from the dock
question of the day very basic question
I'm actually very curious rank these
four platforms in preference Facebook
Twitter snapchat Instagram in your
preference how much you like them you
keep asking questions I'll keep oh 27:12
Patriots this Sunday that is my firm
prediction I I equally do not want that
to happen but I did say on this show
that I wanted them to stick it in my
face and hit rock bottom it looks like
they're trying to execute but they do
cheat and there go all them and I just
lost at least 1700 Patriot fan numbers
are gonna be down that's it I lost them
I liked them I just hate their team you
know like that yeah I don't like that
you know you might see Teddy in Ted this
weekend you might see them yeah I'll go
high-five
all right up Ted I'll go say hey no
Teddy all right cool